so you can
[Music]
[Applause]
perfect yo what's up everybody i am
thomas dopezio whatever you want to call
me and i am here with marty o'neil
what's up guys that was a calm one
this is the dopey usual podcast guys
welcome back we're here to talk about
life drugs problems accomplishments and
everything in between today is going to
be a random one it is a solo episode so
you know it's just me and marty
being me and marty so today guys let's
get straight into this episode
all right here we go all right you guys
ready this is a little breakdown of
what's going on currently marty take
over what are you currently doing right
now
come on i'm sorry man 10 minutes nice
guy clock what are we not doing right
now
that's good
get it we don't want youtube
i've been calling since about 4 am
that's why i'm on yeah now what time is
it now like
eight yeah that's good
yeah so we're putting that work over
here yeah yeah we had a commercial shoot
today marty did not we yeah marty did
yeah
so i've been out in malibu all day
filming with google
for google i should say in a new
commercial they got coming out yeah the
chromebook right
it's a flat screen it's like they got a
bunch of devices they got a watch they
got they got a bunch of stuff rolling
out and like technology to like send it
you know like kind of air cast it to
your devices and stuff but
nice day on set went out there did my
thing hustled they appreciated it now i
got another 12 hour day on set again
tomorrow but it starts at 12. all right
two
yeah right so that's not uh that's
that's a that's a cool day a lot of
times early a lot of times they're like
you got to be there at 6 30 and it's you
know an hour and a half away
that was today and then there'll be two
or three days of that in a row sometimes
sometimes five six days of that in a row
you know but this this was good though
i'm getting my experience up making a
lot of connections and stuff i just like
to say
i don't know any other podcast producers
doing other things besides podcast
producing
yeah there's full-time jobs behind the
show oh yeah no i mean honestly the the
role that i play here with this with all
the [__] that goes into the post and the
editing of the show is like the job of
like four people it's kind of for
brother downs yeah and i saw him go that
is every episode huh
yeah that's like 21 assets every episode
yeah it's just it's a lot post live and
we're still hustling yeah so um
good job man so google this week yeah
yeah google shoot this week then i got
my sister-in-law's graduation from santa
barbara college coming up this weekend
i'm going out there nice
and we'll be back right back at it we
got coming up i think we got more guests
than we can handle honestly yeah that's
what we're doing solo right now guys we
don't want to force it we have so many
guests coming up
i mean
we probably won't be here for 10
episodes it's probably the last solo
until after summer
we'll see how it goes but that's what
it's looking like that is what it's
that's exactly what it's looking like
but i'm not mad at it i'm super excited
for it i'm not gonna even get into it
just super hyped if you watch the show
closely there's only one person i've
ever been like
he's coming on the show okay i gotta get
prepped to get you ready i gotta be on
my toes and we got them so if you're a
fan a close fan you know exactly who
we're talking about and if you don't
i don't even know what episode we
mentioned this man in so
let's just say i'm very excited it's
going to be super cool
i actually cheered there's there's not
been a lot of guests
i lost it i was on my mom's couch i
wasn't missing my for rock was
graduation i was chilling
look i oh man i was hyped
so tight
sorry to tease you guys like that uh
let's get into this marty what time are
we at i don't even need a desk oh the
timer didn't start
how am i gonna bring this
i'm not gonna bring the timer over and
not start half the screen's a timer that
you guys can't see damn it
five minutes oh i gotta wait a little
bit then
um
yeah let's wait just just a little bit a
little bit also while we're waiting
waiting at our own show while we're
waiting for our own show to start guys
uh dope is yola official i believe it is
i'll pop it up on the screen twitch i
just got my entire station set up
solo franklin called me yesterday and
goes yo what's up with this twitch how
do we get this started oh good timing
because my stuff just got set up i
gotcha so one of the first things we're
going to do is we're going to play video
games i saw him just post him yeah
it's going to be cool
it's going to be tight
um are we going to what are you going to
start with like i i did twitch for like
five months straight
and all i did was get high and talk to
people and it was fun
but now i'm going to be more
switch camera let's take a desk switch
camera back to me oh we're doing this
let's look this up oh i can do and i
just want to
make it a routine that i'm always on the
days i say i'm going to be on
like i need to set a schedule
um
but the pc and everything i don't know
any of that stuff but it looks really
cool
looks really awesome it has like tubes
and liquids
i don't know
you guys know more than i do the thing's
got his own little system within a
[__] system on it yeah it does it
does um
wait did i tell you i think i told you
on facetime guys
guys something awesome happened to me
the other day
something super dope
super epic and if you know me you know
how stoked i must be
the other day all right i'm a
storyteller i could just tell you in one
sentence what happened but i'm not going
to do that all right this is what
happened to me the other day rosie and i
go eat a place called sun cafe it's like
a vegan spot in studio city like yo
let's just get [__] oh wait
let's just be sober and just go for a
long drive
for four and a half hour drive the other
day
just driving around neighborhoods and
nice random places
sorry side checked go to the store and
like all the time you know i meet fans
i'm like yo thank you for watching
what's your name because i appreciate it
so i'm standing there going to this tiny
gas station there's only like one or two
people can fit in the gas station you
know there's like drinks and stuff and
the counter you know what kind of gas
station i'm talking about
i go in and i'm like oh there's nobody
here and the cashier comes out from the
bag goes
can i help you like oh yeah i gotta get
some gas and he's doing my thing goes
you make youtube videos man go
yeah i do he goes
you smoke weed on those youtube videos
man go i do he goes i fought i knew i
recognized him like oh that yes he shout
out to yes he shouted to you man chevron
super cool dude right he's like oh man
it's crazy blah blah blah watch your
videos i'm like cool you know like thank
you i do my whole like bro you're the
man thank you for watching
i appreciate it
the reason i say this is because i want
you guys to get into the mode of i'm in
every time someone says like you know
i'm a big i go back in my car like man
that was awesome
how awesome how crazy um
so i'm remember i said that not many
people could fit in the store so as i'm
paying for the gas he goes you do
youtube videos i see a guy at the corner
of my eye a big like a taller white dude
open the door and he looks in and he
just i just see at the corner he stops
like oh there's enough room i'll wait so
you're just waiting at the door you know
being polite
like yo thank you for watching goes dude
i'm a big fan
thank you for making videos mike thanks
for watching man
i turn around are you ready
are you ready for this
i turn around
and i go to the doors two steps away
i look up at the dude like thanks for
holding the door you know i'm like
thanks man and i go thanks he has no
problem and as i say thanks i go
oh my god
you guys know the office is my favorite
show of all time
you guys know this
you guys know how much i love the office
you almost divorced rosie over at
[__] last episode
rose is tripping
michael scott's the funniest are you
ready
i
guys i've met a lot of celebrities
before i smoke weed a lot of slaves i
don't i don't
oh hey nothing right
i don't know what came over me guys i
turned around and i saw gabe lewis if
you don't know who gabe lewis is i
believe he's named zack woods i think
it's zach wood
he's an actor he's in silicon valley
he's a bunch of other stuff he's
hilarious the super tall skinny one gabe
all right gabe from tallahassee in the
in uh
the office i go like this to get through
the door i go thanks man and as i say i
go
i look at him i just go gabe louis
guys i screamed in his face like 112
pieces of cream oh
gabe lewis
i'm a big fan man he went oh thanks man
i need a little fist bump like have a
good day and i walked off just no [__]
rosie was eight feet away but the soda
machine is in front she didn't see any
of it i go rosie
gable with this race shut the [__] up i
go rosie gabe from the
[__] offices right there i told him
like i said thank you so much the kid
was all hyped up made his day i turn
around and go
a big fan
made my whole [__] week bro
that's why every time no matter what i'm
doing i'm gonna stop like yo thank you
for watching i [__] appreciate you
because look that folded into shades oh
thanks man
fist bump made my whole [__] day come
on is that the first time in history
that like somebody's gotten fanned out
on and then turn around and themselves
stand out on somebody
do it oh thank gabe lewis i just yelled
his fictional name
i yelled in his [__] eyes
brian cranston at a dude and it wasn't
even brian cranston yeah we we all know
you told us the story it happens but
yeah bro i finally met somebody from the
office guys my favorite show of all time
and it happened to be gabe lewis i
wanted to scream out quit talking about
the sun
that's one of my favorite lines from the
office that he has ever said guys i know
it sounds stupid made my whole [__]
week i'm talking about it five days
later like i am excited
hell yeah
there's not many more people up on the
list for you in terms of like anybody
from the office that was part of that
that can make me laugh for the rest of
my life i have to say thank you big fan
appreciate you because i [__] do like
yo you have no [__] idea you're going
home
but some people tell me that [__] like
bro you don't realize you're like adam
sandler to me i've had that like
hundreds of times like dude
that's [__] amazing to hear thank you
but i go home get high and do my thing
i'm doing it i appreciate it
it's it's dif i don't know what it is
it's like life long forever like yo when
i am 85 i am still gonna be laughing and
telling my gran i met gabe lewis i met
him at a chevron one time
yeah i could have gone into like seven
office references right now and i'm just
gonna stop
what time are we at we're definitely
like 12 minutes yeah that's why i'm a
smart smoke one of these baby joints i
want to meet the dude from the office
that i did the had the bomb scare with
oh
kevin malone
could you imagine hearing that story
about yourself
a picture of him all scary
um
yeah so that happened and now that we
can smoke weed let's get into this
episode okay sorry i have some i have a
very cool first segment topic and i
really wanted to get high while doing it
i think you guys will be happy too
so for everyone that follows my new
instagram my newest
this is my 27th account nice and fresh
nice and fresh two weeks old only
yola underscore youtube
that's my instagram i'm go to marty's
drastic graphics and i'm sure i'll be
you know the one that he posted that's
me
or the latest one on the bio the latest
one of the bio of the podcast click the
link in the pot in the bio that's my
instagram all right
i asked earlier please give me fan
questions we've done that before but i
asked give me video fan questions send
in a question with yourself talking
i wanted to like
we've said people's names mike 420
johnson we've said people's names before
but never really showed the fan pop up
say their questions so i'm kind of
excited for this i hope
if you're at home and your video pops up
that you're excited as much as i am at
least because it's pretty [__] cool
okay i haven't heard these yet yeah
marty hasn't seen these yet all right i
did these when mario was on his shoot
all right i got it all ready marty was
doing the google stuff isn't that crazy
i was doing the questions while you were
filming for google and then you know he
came over here you want to get high oh
man i was like i was just walking around
here i was kind of frustrated earlier
and i literally as i walked in i'm like
you got the coolest javascript cool job
bro chill the [__] yeah gotta be chill
yep
i think like all the time i am getting
[__]
but i think about that all the time
there's a yin and yang there's you know
what i've been floating there's there's
a reason why it's happening it's because
i can't have that cool of a life bro
there's got to be some turmoil to make
this story worth watching for whoever
made it
it's true
i like thinking about life like that
can't be perfect can't be perfect dude
and if it is
that's die
super tight [__] yeah
if you expect the [__] though know
it's gonna come with the you can roll
with it faster easier you can
turn and lean in uh away from the punch
um here we go guys
these are our questions i asked give us
fan questions send them in marty
load them up who's first and then we'll
play this over the screen
on the episode of this go for it who's
this coming in first we got brock
[__] ftp ftp damn you sound
like a wrestler all right i got a better
question for you mr yola so how old were
you when you rolled your first joint
what was in the joint what did you smoke
who were you with did it burn slow or
not let me know all right brock
talked about this on a lot of season one
the first joint i ever success
successfully rolled by myself i was in
my room i lived on la crescenta with my
mom
i was rolling the joint the first one i
ever successfully rolled i smoked it
dumbest thing i ever did in the house
in my room with my head out the window
like
like it was enough
i'm not a lightweight i don't know what
happened maybe it was like the
relaxation of like wow
indoor smoking like you don't get to do
that [__] as a high school kid
i smoked this it was a little joint like
a .6 i smoked it like more than halfway
that's it
woke up
to pounding punching on my door
open the door my mom's screaming at me
smoking the house what the [__] wrong
with you i'm like mom
no
i didn't and she'll turn around you
[__] idiot i look and it just boxed
this doesn't sound like you that's the
only time i've ever been caught for
smoking ever in my life ever
ever ever ever first time with a droid
she didn't see anything she just saw the
smoking smell and just goes if you smoke
in the house it's gonna beat the [__]
out of you had you been like ripping
bowls and [__] or
yeah i was like 15 years old already
okay i have been smoking his selling
weed already gotcha yeah no i just
my mom wasn't home at the time so i'm
like yo i rolled it stuck oh my god i'm
gonna smoke it right i don't give a [__]
head out the window
and i fell asleep by the window like a
[__] heroin addict
and i even went
did you really fall asleep without
cleaning up you you deserve everything
that happens to you
i am so cautious i can't believe to this
day that i did that still
especially with that that [__]
in the house
hell no
so to answer your question brock i have
no idea what kind of weed it was i was
by myself and almost died
was your standard merced weed straight
trash or because oh just because we were
the younger kids were trying to get zips
those were your weed dealers you want to
announce okay it's 280 and they give me
the one they sell for 200.
was the kids was there like bootleg
dispensaries a factor at all and people
getting weed no yeah well they dispense
we didn't come to merced
i don't think ever i think we've ever
had one dispensary until it got illegal
there's never been a dispensary a legal
spot no there should be drug dealers
uh-huh so you're talking like 2 000 like
10 or whatever
or as far as the dispensaries go a dozen
20.
there was no dispensary until they built
one
there's no dispensaries in recent years
ever no hell no just growing up they're
all legal oh you just go to your
friend's house
okay yeah that changes [__] for me and
those are dispensaries because in my
mind if you grow up in maybe that's just
merced oh la yeah la's huge
merced a cop drives by once goes so it's
right here on m
let's go kick the door in but in l.a
like yo there's 700 buildings i don't
know there's no sign on it we don't know
what's in there and that's how the trap
spots happen in l.a
i see them all the time i see the chat
spots they have what i'm saying i'm not
going to say weed has been legal in in
california this whole time right like
not legal but not illegal
but you couldn't no as it when you were
a kid an adult couldn't go to the store
and buy weed hell no huh there's no
merced county is one of the only
counties in california that did not
approve medical gotcha iraq it took we
were two years late to the party so
that's why it's 2029-2018 when it all
started where 2020. uh-huh that's when
it all like fully went diverse has a
[__] dumb
[__] idiots can't make no [__]
kind of income no kind of money i'm not
talking about people in there i'm
talking about people running it and you
don't want weed your town runs on we use
don't get no the taxes
that was one of them we like our people
on meth yeah we like our people on meth
no hope
we don't want any kind of hope
um all right sorry brooke
go for it what's the next question
we got eric g coming in eric g
erg looking like he might be your
illegitimate son out here
what's good everyone at the dope as
usual podcast my name is eric and
today's question i have for y'all is
what's the best route uh that you would
recommend somebody take if they're
trying to get into the cannabis industry
and what are some do's and don'ts of
trying to get into this industry because
i know a lot of people [__]
opportunities up very good ones as well
because of some stupid [__] they did
thank you so much for answering my
question y'all thank you for your time
and dope as usual to the moon push trees
to the moon let's get it baby eric i
like the enthusiasm yeah i like the
enthusiasm eric g
oh
how to get in the industry go on the
dopazioli youtube channel
go about a week back watch the super low
viewed video because it's shadow man age
restricted and [__] blocked
it's called how to get into the industry
that's exactly what you just asked how
to get in the industry i give a 44
minute seminar
ted talk ted talk on every single
[__] piece of thing you can think of
when it comes to legal market how to get
in from five dollars an hour or whatever
to making millions of dollars charge for
i'm sure i should have charged for but
i'm not also youtube did not like that
they really went hard with the
no views on this
it does it's like a 50 000 views in a
week it's crazy
my chan i'm not saying low views is
[__] i'm saying that's such a good
video it should be everywhere that's so
educational what the [__] you got
restricted
anyway eric g go watch it you're looking
for a lighter
i got one okay i can see it on your face
you're touching your pants while doing
this
that's a lighter look
uh are you sure you got one because i
got one right here
all right so uh yeah eric
go watch how to get into the industry
the do's and don'ts i don't really have
do's and don'ts but i give you all the
do's i don't really have any don'ts
i give you all the do's in that video
it's 44 minutes long go check it out um
sure marty popped up the
thumbnail on the screen somewhere so
eric go watch it how to get into the
industry on the dopagiola channel marty
who we got up next what's his name
refused to lose refuse to lose dot crook
dot crook go for it let's go
so as you know man when you take a drug
test it'll pop up as thc when you smoke
a weed
but since you know
it's delta eight will pop up as hhc or
what will come up
delta a
um okay uh that was a little confusing
but let me answer i think
he's saying what will pop up on a test
for hhc thedopashop.com we have hhc we
it's not thc so it's legal that's why
we're allowed to ship it to every door
every state every county that's why
we're able to do that
hhc
will pop up on a test if someone's
testing for hhc
do you know what i'm saying it's not
going to show up in your weed test
because they test for thc
it's still pre it's going to be there
it's like saying oh did you eat bananas
and we're going to test you like okay
yeah i ate [__] bananas and you're
testing for bananas [__] i'm
gonna be present i know it's a weird
description but that's as simple as that
they're not gonna be like yeah and you
had 12 coconut juices yesterday like no
you just for bananas how do you know
do you see what i'm saying it's kind of
like absurd like you would never test
positive thc
it's got it's only hhc it's the it's the
weirdest i'm trying to find a
description you go oh yeah that makes
perfect sense yeah so hopefully my
stupid banana inaliena no that was good
it was just two different things
they're different that's confusing
though because it seems like it's all
coming from the same place it's hc and
it's from the same plant yeah it's a
different compound it's a different uh
cannabinoid that's all it is guys that's
all it is it's different cannabinoid it
doesn't show up on hh thc test because
they don't test for it maybe one day
they'll have an hhc test
and then you're [__]
buy up now
by the [__] out of it now smoking [__]
out of it but with delta h delta nines
i'm not too
savvy on that
not really sure i do know delta eight
delta nine is not as strong
i hit those [__] pen on that on set
well that was sad
yeah and man i was because i didn't
smoke all day you hit that pen without
smoking you're like oh i'm cool those
are serious
those are serious
i always describe hhc is
hey you know if you smoke a joint say
you're high as a 10 smoke a hc joint
you're like in a seven five
like oh
okay so it's not as strong but yeah it's
not as strong but it's almost [__]
right there okay so why would i smoke
that like
because i can ship it to you yeah ship
it to your [__] door doesn't even
smell yeah and it's like yo want to go
on this website and buy weed legally
yeah i do well now you can to
thedobashop.com so check it oh yeah
skateboard in the back that's the next
giveaway right there boy
if you saw last week the [__]
playstation xbox that was another
giveaway
um but yeah we're giving a bunch of
stuff away it's fun
so that was your to answer your question
it should not i've had like eight people
tell me you're a piece of [__] i tested
positive for thc smoking your stuff like
you're a [__]
liar i'm sorry that you really but they
really think that it was that
it's impossible it's like saying i
tested for heroin but i'm on cocaine
yeah it's like bro what
we don't sell that
the [__] oh the light's not on i just
noticed it's not lit up
you're all good that's fine um
i knew something was different
uh but yeah that's that's to answer your
question it shouldn't but i've had more
i mean hundreds of people go yo test it
clean oh yeah you should
[__] tease you free that's the point
but yeah that's the answer that question
sorry i'm kind of loopy right now i feel
like i'm just
babbling let's get back on track dude
what are most people going for when they
go to the dopashop.com is it the carts
is it the pre-rolls is the gummies
everything sells
pretty equally that's insane yeah
everything people love the joints and
when they constantly buy them what about
flavors is there one that stands out
the ones that sell the hardest are like
girl scout cookies
um
the skywalker og
because those are like strains that
people can already like
have already accustomed to yeah so they
already know what to expect
i didn't i've been doing research
because i got this little brand deal for
a weed adjacent company
i didn't realize like yeah there's a
dozen cannabinoids going into your
experience and the terpenes and like the
thc percentage air con we posted this
should i read thc percentage really
doesn't have much to do with your
experience
per this little article and it does in
the placebo terms in the place yeah
oh this is 38
but i just told you 17 you would have
went oh it's pretty strong uh-huh yeah
like i think a lot of it is placebo that
i've always felt like indica sativa i
can't i don't know the dirt i can't i
can't
i'll tell you the difference but my
body's i'm so [__] sensitive to
things i can tell like
when i'm gonna be sick tomorrow or two
days like i don't know it's very weird
like
so i taste that i feel like oh oh as a
hybrid
i can feel it in my head
it pissed me off though cause i go by
that thc percentage
like do you just stick to the [__]
ogs yeah and smoke them
they're always gonna be
they're staples all right this the
exotics they're great they're cool
not everybody can grow exotics right oh
gee this is so strong it's just no even
if you [__] it up it's still going to be
pretty strong that's how i see that's
why i smoke it nonstop
but i am going to switch it up
i did switch it up to some [__]
biscotti purple [__]
[__] the stuff we smoking on the tony
hawk show oh as you got me hi
ain't that crazy to say well we've
interviewed tony hawk that's right
as well
it's [__] awesome
um sorry yes on to the next question
who is it sorry i'm in that same thought
though
how long until we unleash this
[__] hey abby on these people
oh i can't really show them yet
there's supposed to be a machine behind
marty but it makes noise because it has
a fan and it just it picks up on the mic
so we had to move it the whole point i
wanted to be right there so you can see
it in the back go on the dopaziola
channel another age-restricted video
[__] views again but i really love
this video it's called hey abby oh no
the machine is called hey abby the video
is called
excuse me
my first weed grow and a lot of people
well that's why it's age restricted man
no i called it my first grow
and then he got age retreats because i
changed to my first week girl said
[__] goal go all out
so go watch that video it's a [__]
weed growing machine
and when i say that it's a it's a
machine that grows weed i there's the
easiest way to put it i can talk to this
[__]
i it's voice activated
all you do is drain the water from your
app
once a week
put two things of food on the thing and
itself [__] feeds
the thing's growing it is as big as my
chest
it is a
if you watched the video what eight no
12 days ago that little clone was right
here right about that big around
i haven't done anything i haven't not a
scientist
i didn't do anything i left for set for
three days came back what the [__]
guys this [__] is this big
it's not gonna fit in that machine i'm
gonna have to crop it a little bit and
[__] with it because it's it's gonna be
too big this [__] plan is growing how
much longer is that cycle supposed to be
like another
seven weeks six weeks that's not too bad
we'll be literally in here grinding
those buds down yes what the [__] and in
the video i go so that machine you see
behind marty just remember we're gonna
smoke that [__] but it was too loud it
picked up on the mics our mics are
sensitive as [__]
we had this we had to move it but
if you watch my snapchat the dopest yola
you saw me do all my updates yesterday
my water draining my [__]
lolly not lollipopping uh the trellis
putting the magnets and spreading it so
the sun gets down it's the [__]
future it's [__] cool dude so yes the
hey abby does work
it is [__] cool and it is awesome
it's so cool it's so crazy you walk in
there just a bright it's like a blue
[__] alexa light yeah it looks like
tech like there's no way somebody could
walk in and not be like that's weird
yeah no one would ever know what it is
and they would always go what is it it
looks like wally it looks like a it
looks like robot it looks like a robot
you're a hundred percent right
it's awesome all right so go watch that
video on the dopaziola channel it's
called my first wheat grow
um okay ready next question ryan
dopizzola
love the content
what is something that you wanted to
release like hhd product but the
technology hasn't
got to that level yet
i'm high as soon as he started talking i
was like what's up dude
i am [__] burnt dude
that just happened
um it's okay i almost did that a minute
ago so you know we're here things we do
um before i answer this question thank
you guys all for being here this is fun
it's our job marty's [__] crazy it's
our job i [__] love i would say i'm
so thirsty
yo marty got a middle and you brought me
one i forgot thank you thank you sir
uh this is our [__] job so thanks
guys it's pretty cool
uh
yeah right let's go let's get on to it
ryan
it sounds like my uncle john's backyard
that was very odd right now
just
got me
um
there's no product that we can't make
man
i'm not gonna give the name away
wait marty you can bleep this
okay
we might be making drinks
i'm gonna say it fast you can bleep it
and i'm gonna cover my mouth so they
can't get it
we're gonna make medicated
okay so cut out you can leave it you can
make medicated and bleep what i said so
nobody steals my [__] okay
we're gonna call them
god
i'm so pissed i didn't think of that
what a [__] jewel what a gem
oh [__]
i can't let you guys in on that one yet
we're making something from the dopest
shop it's an edible
what's the name the name i know
all the times you go marty that was a
good one
that was my good one
you came up with that no oh
i was in i was doing all the comments
it's like two and a half years ago i was
doing comments
and i was like in deep comments like
three in the morning and i saw comments
like yo if you ever make it edible you
should say this and call it this
a light hit me and i like i [__]
started levitating in my [__] couch
and went yo shut the [__] up i
screenshotted it there's no way i'm ever
gonna find the screenshot after being
deleted 38 times getting new phones and
it's not
but i did if i ever do this and you see
that i do this please contact me with
this [__] comment
because i need to give that [__]
credit and some money
but yo here's a finders fee because that
name
bomb yes i don't have to but that's
going to make me feel better going that
fan out there is going to sleep tonight
going yeah shut the [__] up
and i just need to give them some money
they get no percentage or nothing [__]
you i gotta do this [__] by myself it's
just a good name it's a great name yeah
i was gonna stumble upon that
[__] at some point yeah that's
great if we were gonna do that edible
anyway but to call it that and to pitch
it that way
genius yes makes me go damn that wasn't
mine
that wasn't mine
but we'll continue um so to answer your
question uh
what was his name was it ryan
clipped off it wasn't top it was ryan
right yeah it was ryan ryan first off
shout out to you for having the pen in
your hands starting just right off the
bat how's the [__] there you go just has
the pen
um
nothing is impossible
okay
i will give you a little thing we are
coming out with story time joints
i'm going to roll [__] join just like
i do in story time and then we're just
going to mass produce it
damn like a a fat ass three and a half
dab
a big ass tube that's a good idea it's a
great idea right story time joint
[__] out of here
three and a half grammar
that's all i'll give you guys right now
we have something
no i can see the font i can see this
this product shot on a lazy susan
spinning with black background so it's
like in the abyss
exactly i can see it already
so thanks ryan
thank you for your question yeah there's
nothing we can't we're gonna keep our
land yeah we have so much we have so
much we just dropped
10 packs of joints so you could buy 10
packs now
we're dropping oh this will be out by
then i think our nerd rope clusters and
nerd ropes drop next week i haven't
talked about them yet
[__] bob
nerd ropes and everything sour gummy
sharks apple sour watermelon gummy
sharks
hold on hold on sour apple gummy shark
sour watermelon sour watermelon and then
on top of that we have the ultra sour
gummy and ultra sour watermelon they're
so [__] sour hurting my face
made me sweat i remember oh
yeah you saw facetime you instantly saw
me just
oh i don't know what it is about sugar
in me it doesn't mix and i start getting
all sweaty and [__] it's stupid
i miss candy
i miss eating candy
i try not to touch it here we go
next question
thank you ryan
okay okay okay hold on i got this
question i just [__] save i don't
care what your question is this is um
this is incredible this dude's got
commitment yes so his name is from
scream screamface182
or tristan i see you pop up it's either
in this live chat or it's in the youtube
or i mean the instagram comments but i
see that name all the [__] time so
shout out to you for always being here
thank you let it roll
hello
my question to you is what's your
favorite movie from the 90s
this one and friday okay one second hold
on
i like this guy tristan yeah me too
because he knew how to comedically add
that last beat and friday
with a knife
so everyone driving this man is in a
full scream you know the movie scream
he's in a full screen mask get up
costume and he has the knife with the
voice changer box on
and he says what's your favorite 90s
movie
you know he's playing this part well i
love this guy i just part well i did a
thing on instagram one time where i said
i'm gonna follow however many people
comment and follow the podcast or
whatever and he was one of them i only
follow like 200 smart people
oh my god it's a little total that's all
i follow on instagram and like oh a
total oh it's like you
i said i'm going to follow 35 people
because i hit like 35k or some [__] but
i ended up just following everybody
you're the man and he was one of them
this little makes he his whole timeline
is videos in character of this yes it's
incredible yes i love that that's so
cool
so uh for everyone at home he's in a
costume can you play his question again
and hold on listen to the variant after
he says it mine's this one listen
hello podcast my question to you is
what's your favorite movie from the 90s
this one and friday
and friday
i love it dude
my favorite 90s movie bro there's no way
i can say that there's no way it's
impossible it's hard to do it i mean
forest gump's what 96 that's my was all
my all-time favorite movie
can we just say 1996 was probably the
best years of all time you've said that
to me in music and movies 14 different
occasions
can we just talk about 96 i'm gonna do a
whole episode on 1996. you said this to
me multiple times i really could let's
just do an episode on 1996 call it 1996.
party it's one of those years
what do you think about those years man
i really could you could go back i think
76 the mid 70s when pig floyd and all
them had their stretch that was a
creative there's something going on a
lot of great art going on mid
decade yeah then like 96 maybe just
because i was you know 10. but like
you if you look at all the classic
albums and all the everything that
dropped that yeah that came off here
it's insane will smith jim carrey chris
farley
you know what's going on i think i've
solved it guys i think i've solved the
human brain when it comes to movies and
celebrities you want to hear my theory
marty
oh you ready
i think
the 90s
was so
influential and so
prevalent today
is because
50 60s yeah we had movie stars yeah we
had all that that's cool
mtv all right i'm 70s we had
[__] pools were blowing up there were
movie stars there was [__]
blockbusters there was star wars already
star wars was [__] out
michael jackson was out
it's common common era
80s cameras get better
movies get better
90s some of those cameras we still use
you know i mean yeah 90s was oh
everything's perfected almost nothing's
really changed since the 90s so we're in
this like box of this is when it got
good enough to last right before
computers yes right before any this is
now it's lasting also
the reason people were killing
themselves when michael jackson died
remember that people were committing
some people committing suicide when he
died i don't know about that i watched
the whole [__] thing there was people
in other countries die killing
themselves over because they love this
[__] so much they were dying
crazy
but
think about it
michael jackson might be one besides
kurt russell might be one of the only
people you saw
in the 60s a movie star dies 70s moose
star dies the 80s movie started as okay
yeah they died it's super sad 90s 2000s
and up
we've seen those people grow up as a kid
we've seen them grow and mature have
kids have a [__] life have a scandal
have then they die
so you lost one of your friends when
prince died my mom was [__]
heartbroken with my mom since she was 14
15 like loves all his [__] loves him
seen him live has and he [__] died so
when when i feel like
when we see people grow up and they're
famous from younger and then we see
macaulay cocon is getting older and you
know there's like a 50 year old man out
there go i remember that was like 25
when homo came out
like yo you're [__] 60 bro
damn near you've seen that kid as you
know grow from this to that that's why i
think people are like so i love this
movie star and then people like how are
people so in love with movies it's their
friend they never met
yeah
for sure
the that's the feeling that you get i've
never met him saying i [__] love that
dude since i was a child
it's a different feeling when it's like
you've seen someone's life grow and i
think that's why the 90s and the 96 and
all that [__] sticks so this what do you
think in 96 i think will smith heavy
yeah it sticks in my head
well smith was getting popping around i
think bruce willis sometimes because he
was still popping jim carrey a hundred
and fifty percent right
those are the things that like really
really really get hit me like 90s i just
think because that's and it's for us
because it's when we started growing up
yeah but the 90s it's for people 10
years old and 10 years younger still we
were just lucky we were just born in the
right time
but the time is like
when kobe bryant died bro we watched
that kid since he was 18 years old i was
[__] six when he got drafted
he [__] dies
he's a part of your life it's a part of
your life yeah it's not like oh marlon
brando passed away
yeah yeah you've seen him you've never
seen 35 interviews you had johnny carson
that's all you had to see the person's
what they were behind you know them and
there can be a layer of like oh this
person really inspired me because i'm on
the same path as them and i always like
looked up to how they did it i think
that's what it is
that's why people connect so hard when
people die now it's like
[__]
it's way different you know what i mean
i see some people like well get over you
don't even know that [__] but i
don't have to know the [__] to
be affected by it yeah that's why i
think people are so connected with
celebrities and [__] now
not every celebrity but when you bring
up 1996 like why my love was
off he was crushing it i was thinking
the [__] ups bad boys [__] i just
think of will you know i mean i think of
jim carrey
lanky [__] liar like i just think
about those legends
yes so you think of those things but
somebody say that from the 80s
and that person dies they're like yo
what
the [__] like george michael george
michael passed away young as [__]
it's weird like i wasn't young enough to
remember his come up
i wasn't born but when you see someone
grow and you see them like skyrocket and
then they die it's like what the [__]
it's like your friend you haven't seen a
long time past you hear they pass away
like what wow
that's how i feel about
when people i don't know i don't know
it's just a weird thing so when you
think 96 was the best [__] year
because you connected with that [__]
yeah you know so i think that's why
people are so into celebrities like yo
i've been watching this for over 30
years
but even way more so now because like
back in 96 when you were a celebrity we
only saw you when you came out to do
everything or extra [__] extra
it was an exciting moment just to see
you do anything else outside of acting
anything yeah anything but now you wake
up in the first like it's the rock
i love the rock but you see his face
every day yeah it's different but that's
why people are more connected now
yeah when they see a celebrity pass away
they go to their last post and go man
they were alive five hours ago this is
so [__] sad
because you're now you get to see
people's last moments and thoughts and
ideas and goals that's why it's so much
it's worse now yeah cause you're like
straight connect with somebody you can
see them [__] post with their family
their story's still up that's the bad
one you see rappers die you go like damn
his story is still
yeah
[__]
that's what makes it worse now because
like i was saying
back in the [__] 70s it was just
johnny carson man you couldn't do
anything there was just late night shows
there was no
interview shows and [__] vlad tvs and
all that [__]
you know so it's it's a it's a little
different now but i think that that's
what i broke down the other day like why
is it so important to me because i grew
up with them
i've seen their whole life
when you see somebody a celebrity that's
smaller and they get popped like yeah i
love that fooling that [__] me off so
yeah now he's a superstar that's sick
you get like a sense of like good [__]
keep going
when you're not a piece of [__] hater
sorry if you don't feel that way you
might be a [__] [__]
what do i care about if a guy makes me
like can't you just be happy that
someone did
no
you might be an [__]
so that's the feeling i think i think we
get and to sum it up for you marty my
long rant
1996 was a bomb yes okay guys we're
talking [__] east 1999 eternal
we're talking dmx coming out it's dark
and hell is hot hard knock life
survival of the elves tour def jam come
on not to mention even the r b we're
talking miss educational warren hill you
got
fuji's [__] going on hip hop was taken
off the 80s hip-hop was dying
you had actual rock music at its yeah
that that era of it had its peak corn
and all them 96 was everything it was
music mtv was [__] everything when
mtv was still good and when football
still mattered was the best time in in
on earth i think
when people still gave a [__] about
football
was the best the 90s were just the best
i think they were the coolest they're
before social media but at the peak of
like yo we need more mm-hmm
and then social media came and ruined it
before that uh-huh
it was bomb i wish it was so poor
people's attention was different i mean
that game was it for the week
like oh yeah my kids can't not be on
their [__] devices they have they get
they're like addicts they can't [__]
that's the point though
you need your brain to be doing this
and when it's not you go what the [__]
do i i felt like i just sat and stared
at the floor a lot as a kid like i just
oh yeah as a kid i just waited for the
next day
all the time i told them that like
they're like what am i supposed to do
be bored i don't know nothing just
thinking so bored before
i've been bored normally explode
sorry hold on
tristan
did we never introduce yourself on the
screen
i'm sorry
my favorite 90s movie man
i don't know he knew what he was doing
he knew
how are you going to go you know liar
liar was in that and the mask but also
you know michael keaton batman
tommy boyd
[__] [__] oh you mean happy
gilmore oh oh okay oh you mean all right
oh got you got you guys for sure dick
first
no pulp fiction in uh [__]
training day yeah no it's all good
anyway train day's 99 correct
it's in the 90s somewhere everything's
96. it's in the 90s somewhere he says
sorry tristan to answer your question i
can't answer your question
it's
it's either saying you want to breathe
smoke weed or smoke weed and breathe
like
both if i can that's basically asking
your all-time favorite movie because for
me yeah good movies stopped at wolf of
wall street we it was wolf of wall
street need to watch more movies
i know with this i know then there was
avatar was good and then there's the 90s
wolf of wall street which brings me on
to a slight topic wolf of wall street
was essentially goodfellas corporate
it was a voiceover of the handsome
younger dude that comes up and gets rich
henry hill all right
the voice over the stops the animation
the this and that's when everything took
over and that's when this guy oh and
then i had to spend the rest of my life
as a schnook at the end and that's how i
spent the rest of my life [__] doing
seminars it's the same [__] movie
also thanks mom
let's go look at this nobody knows what
the [__] that is people know that people
know okay someone out there knows this
shirt if you're not at home one dog goes
this way one dog goes the other way oh
looks like someone we know don't we pans
to the [__] window
to the trunk
this is good fellas this is the painting
that joe pesci's mom painted
when they killed benny blatts or
whatever his name was when they killed
the [__] stomped him out stabbed
him with a [__] pen did all that
crazy [__] they were in the kitchen
and then in the kitchen talking to joe
pesci's mom he's like oh hoof
we gotta get the knife yeah we hit a
deer and you know the hoof is so sad
like we gotta get the and then robert de
niro the hoof yeah yeah with a [__]
knife a fork with a shirt you know my
memory is very odd and then when he's
talking i painted this ma you [__]
painted this
this is the painting my mom sent me a
picture that this is on a shirt go mom
buy it from me right now please do you
get your deep references from your mom
like is she like that too or is this
just oh she knows she knows a lot of
[__] such a dude she knows a lot of [__]
but yeah what a shirt what a [__]
shirt i rocked this [__] today because
i and to bring me into my piece woof of
wall street loved it great movie it is
essentially
white people good fellas
am i wrong
it's stock market criminals instead of
italian mobsters took a different route
both end up at the [__] same
both [__] lives not stoked looking at
the camera and this is how i spend the
rest of my life well that's just a crime
story i know but it's a martin scorsese
movie okay it's the exact same language
oh i didn't realize that he uses the
young temple
rape shout out to ray leonard i'm so sad
that was so sad that was [__] up man
like yo ray leona passed away and that's
another thing when you're talking about
celebrities i only think
young ray liotta on the outside when he
steals a truck with young joe pesci and
you think of young
you think of the young kid
you know what i mean yeah that's why
it's like oh
man ray leona passed away
that's
oh man that's sad
you ha
and people always say why do you care
about celebrity it's [__] what
i was born on this is what i was raised
on the storyteller i love is dead it
reminds me [__] you better go cause
like
he had his time that was his time yeah
and we know him that he was in his time
his time has passed
but yes how what a looped wearing this
shirt
and all that [__]
i think i mean wolf walsh there's no pl
the plot's not the same there's nothing
it's not the same movie i'm talking
about if
you had to just go give reasons poor and
he got rich and you know he got [__]
up you're talking about when they were
taught when they were sitting in the
room making this they're like all right
just we're going to start yeah just like
just like that no no
narration of the main character yes no
no over this over the movie yeah we'll
bring the music in
leonardo dicaprio is ray liotta
yeah that it's martin scorsese's golden
boy right now he's in every movie of
that fools right now
that just kind of reminded me of a quick
kind of thought i wanted to throw out
there real quick because i watched the
show
on hulu called candy it was it's a based
on a true story sounds familiar
and justin timberlake was in it as a
sheriff
and i was a sheriff yeah did he have a
mustache at beard i hope i think so yeah
i can't take him serious without it no
but i was just i had a moment where i
was like is justin timberlake like he's
got to be one of the most powerful
talented [__] bro ever
and then singing dancing acting like
crush is it you know he's got to be way
up there but then i was just thinking
about acting and really it's got to be
leo leo he's one of the best ever denzel
like
and he doesn't have a ton of shitty
movies you can look at denzel and be
like oh he's had a whole like so past 20
years have been nothing
like his hits were in the 90s that's
living actor i think daniel day lewis
you know who that is
crushes uh-huh he embodies characters
but hold on entertaining best actor
probably leonardo dicaprio yeah right
now
because you can play so many roles
dustin hopkins is a great actor but he's
old he can only play old man roles
when you see leo on basketball diaries
is this that's the one i always think of
when he's crying with his [__] nose
running right yeah it's a crime that
that's not out russia you can't rent
that if anybody can find a link let me
know find the movie called basketball
diaries that's one of the movies my mom
played for me and showed me lessons see
what happened she would pause and go see
what happens you don't listen to your
mom he's outside screaming at his mom on
drugs that's what happens you don't
listen to me that's my mom used to do
that all the time i remember being like
five and i was at some kid in the
neighborhood's house and they had it on
i shouldn't be watching this i like i
[__] left out of the house
mid movie didn't watch it you left yeah
i was a little boy that [__] was
disturbing
yeah [__] my mom was pressing pause
and teaching me life lessons while
watching it
i'm telling you i i got instructed
through a lot of [__]
basketball diaries is one of the best
movies of all time yes young marky mark
and there's a monster
we ought to be able to go through like
to depict having withdrawal from heroin
heroin as a 15 16 year old actor he
[__] destroys that movie yeah it's
just him basically yeah the whole movie
yeah
it's dark crush is that [__]
unreal loves it loved it
um yo we our rant our rant staying on
track [__] not good oh not good cause i
looked up we're in fan questions still
oh [__] yeah
you [__] they're all little branches
from the channel
they are it's like lightning like here's
those questions
here's your answer
it's like those movies or those
commercials like are you having problems
breathing and they show a person that
goes in it's just all their bronchial
tubes oh [__] yeah that's our our [__]
that's us
but it's okay exactly yeah oh leonardo
captain the best act of all time
uh danny daley might be the best
but
yeah leonardo carbo crushes man crushes
heavily denzel's the best actor of all
time that plays the same character every
role
i can't wait to put that not see that
now it's a good way to put that
vince vaughn too
no you've seen clay pigeons no i don't
know these obscure clay pigeons is a you
know what i realized the other day guys
for everyone out there has been watching
me for a long time i always say you know
my movies and music my mom everything
i have to take this back
classic rock and early 90s movies are
the only movies i got from my mom
i just realized
every single [__] thing is my uncle
john
every every i was thinking you never
seen it where did i watch it john
zero the crooked
john andre nicotina john
i started thinking things do in denver
when you're dead
john
almost everything in
evil dead all of them john
everything in my [__] life after 12
11 is
because my uncle john showed me
now that i'm thinking about it giving
monster much credit no no she's awesome
but kind of
because i kind of think i'm like no no
that was no that was john
and almost all my [__] rap is from
john
almost all of it
it's a trip man like me thinking about
this now
wait
everything under fifth grade is all my
mom other than that that's it
it's a trip dude and everything after 18
is me did she realize he was influencing
you so much
no
i have a great memory so i remember what
i heard when i heard it
i remember the first time i heard andre
katie's song i was taking a right into
our driveway the apartments
blaine's house is here this is [__]
olive
taking a right we hit the dip
and coming in and i went what is this
the first time i heard on jane katina
saw on the blood in my hair song it's
the [__] blast the mohicans damn
danny lewis it's the last of the
mohicans [__] theme beat but he's a
hip-hop beat and he raps over hard as
[__] i love andre nicotina so [__]
much he's so hard anyway one favorite is
all the time uncle john
i can't think of anything that i like
that's not directly related because john
showed me
damn
it's weird was he all into adam sandler
and should have you too he likes damn
sandler they they made amazing legoland
without me
[__] bastards he sat right behind him
at legoland oh [__]
adam sandler just closed a lego lane
like a civilian well my little cousin
memphis was like hi adam sadler because
he was a kid at the time but yeah they
met adam sandler i didn't i was so sad
um
you saw howdy mandel while he was
reading up and [__] merced though he
was freeing up right what the [__] was
he there
well he was freeing up
um sorry for this long rant
yes almost everything [__] john go
back we were at the we're at skyler we
didn't do skyler's yet we didn't nope
all that mean hit his answer yes oh [__]
we'd even press play yet [__] okay we
didn't even press play sorry next
question this one's not the best and i
don't know how many times you've
answered it i watch you religiously so
if you've answered it it must not be on
any of your videos but i just want to
know what was your favorite absolute
favorite weed event to go to of all time
and also if you did mention in your
videos i apologize for missing that
skyler bancroft i see that [__]
name in the live chat
of youtube a lot i see a [__]
tupac hanging up behind them yeah the
drawing i see it too
yeah i see it so that's
the first thing i noticed earlier yeah
oh two parts okay yeah skyler bancroft
shout out to you for being the [__]
chat if it's the same one but it has to
be
same guy in the [__] live chat all
the time for the podcast it's a
different different guy
thank you so much for being here man
your answer to your question my favorite
weed event ever
they're all blended so bad so i will
tell you my favorite one that i can
remember distinct i mean no no i won't
say i know i can differentiate a lot of
them got so repetitive
my favorite one ever was my first one
the denver one the video i i took down
off youtube but
um
that was my favorite one
whether you almost broke in a pound
joint died in the plane on the way back
yes
nice there you go
yes that's the same yeah of course it's
the same one yeah in the story time
going through the pictures with justin
boyd and the big joint that's the pound
joint
yes the same one that almost died upon
yourself it was my favorite event
oh yeah
i remember thinking i
[__] the of it i wouldn't even came
that's remember thinking of the plane
yeah marty same [__] event but also
my favorite worst plane ride
best event hopefully that's my worst
plane ride of all time
man i know i could go life without doing
another plane ride i [__] hate plans
i'd rather just jog it out
i'll give a [__] i'll pull up i'm tired
now like a forrest gump with the whole
crowd behind me
but yeah i follow that guy just jogging
like
all right forest had the original
followers
yeah he had a whole [__] tweet system
behind him yeah bunch of [__]
so what do we do
yeah that's symbolic
forest is ahead of his [__] time he's
a slow man
what a [__] purple heart could have
won the m double or the [__]
ncaa [__] championship with those
[__] legs
a baller met the president was on tv as
a billionaire we're sitting next to a
millionaire
and he's slow he makes me feel dumb
he makes me feel lazy
attentive father and he defeated aids
are you gonna give me the little sister
that's bigger than the big sister he
might have spades
stop playing stop playing stop playing
he went like that
on this windshield with age and then
[__] bounced yeah we're never going
to be monetized when we ever
we're never going to be on tv
the [__] we say eating chips and [__]
oh
he's trying to dodge that girl in the
parking lot it's one of the best scenes
in any [__] comedy i do that [__] to
the kids oh yeah yeah oh i do the
[__]
oh all the time it's and if you don't
understand i go oh that's sad
sucks for you
this is mine and friday [__] [__]
tristan
yeah let's go here we go
what the [__] were you talking about
favorite weed event
[Laughter]
oh i'm on i'm in my mind i'm going say
it again say what again
say what again i think i got a
girlfriend man and a wife on the side
yo pinky pinky's funny you guys up to
the old ladies you can't be selling
[__] around here
pinky pinky pinky
is p
is pinky the same [__] from
bulletproof with damon williams and adam
sandler
is he the [__] cop
can you look that up is pinky the cop
from bulletproof
yo i'm a [__] master
if he is the same cop from bulletproof
that is a very small role clifton powell
please being bulletproof oh my god
please being [__] bulletproof
we're going to find out please be a
[__] bulletproof a very not thought
of adam sandler movie
come on bulletproof is that 96 also
i don't caught up
no hold on hold on i'm gonna do some
research
i tried to see those yourselves right
hold on i might be wrong
no that's him
i told you
don't kill him and damon williams pulls
him close and you go
no that's that's him he's the dude from
uh he's that's the guy that's the guy
this is my society too
that's him that's him in bulletproof
that has to be him in bulletproof here
we go rush hour next friday blastog
i got the hookup
it's not him it's not him is it ah
he's got so many [__] movies wrong
man he's got so i might not be able to
get to them
i'm wrong man if you haven't found a
wrapped top it's a bigger movie
i'm wrong guys holy [__]
wrong reference he's the dude and um
in menace that's like he has the white
dude coming to his door who's
you i mean the white dude's coming to
his door trying to get him to rob car
parts and [__]
he's like in society in south central
while drinking your juice in the hood
the original one
i'm sorry
yeah the white dude coming to his door
and he's all scared he's like i thought
i told you not to come around this
[__] so early yo like it's 1 pm
i was thinking
i was thinking of somebody else a
different way
yeah
a different
you know that family is just crushing
life
yo we got 76 [__] brothers and
sisters 48 of them are famous
that's a great percentage for real of a
millionaire these numbers aren't that
exaggerated
sorry
the [__] are we talking about hey what's
up guys thank you so much for watching
this episode and we just wanted to take
a minute to talk about one of our
sponsors this is sea geek right now guys
do me a favor go to the app store and
download the app seek geek and after you
download the app remember to use our
code when you check out dope as usual
that's 20 off any ticket so if you don't
know what i'm talking about let me
explain sea geek to you right now you
want to go see the lakers you want to go
see i don't know usher you want to see a
concert you want to see anything you're
going to go on the website you're going
to find a ticket and buy it but if you
look for your ticket through seatgeek
you're going to get the number one best
price on the internet by far guys i
personally mean rosie personally use
this app and have used this app it's as
easy as this type in the event the
sporting event the concert you want to
go to the tickets will pop up just like
always and it'll direct you to the best
price for those seats so if it's a green
dot next to it it means it's the best
deal you're going to get if you're going
to go to a concert you're going to go to
an event why wouldn't you want to save
money so on top of seed geek having the
best prices on the internet remember
once you download the app and you buy
your ticket whatever you get use code
dope as usual at checkout you're gonna
get 20 no matter how much it is but you
guys got to remember use our code dope
as usual and that's 20 off your first
ticket as always guys thank you so much
for supporting the brands that support
us back to the episode
pinky we made a friday reference sorry
guys
we did this and then you said all i
could say is here say what again yep
guys go watch next friday don't watch
next friday all right go watch next
friday go watch basketball diaries just
do us a [__] favor what time are we
at like 55 we're in the first segment
105. shut the [__] up marty
we gotta we gotta get through this
because this [__] gotta go film
for google and this got to be edited
yo marty i only put a couple notes
because i thought we're in the [__]
fan questions still it's okay yeah it's
okay let's get on to this next question
all right
this is from
okay so this is from
talia rank talia rink
so thomas what do you do with your
reclaim do you dab it do you capsule it
up do you eat it do you make edibles out
of it what do you do with your reclaim
i've never heard of this
okay i can answer that simple and i'll
explain to you what's going on
i wash it down the drain
i know i do nothing with it you know
what reclaim is marty yeah it's like
when you're dabbing for your dabs right
yes
perfect
it's resin for your dabs you can collect
that [__]
and re-dab it all this is dabs that
didn't get burned and it's plopped in
the water all you just let it dry out
and you [__] dab all your weakling
even if it's all wet and [__] yeah just
let it dry
okay or you can take it put in capsules
and eat it
and it works you can [__]
capsules oh it's not fun
i don't i don't i don't advise it
you can make edibles out of it too
dude you can do so much with your
reclaim i'm sorry i'm a bougie [__] i
don't have time to be doing this
i don't do anything with my reclaim guys
i don't dab as much as i used to either
so
i no i do nothing with my reclaim
but there's not always not enough we are
my to everything i have is so [__]
precise that it's
there's not a lot of reclaim not a lot
of [__] gets sucked on the neck hardly
ever honestly
and with a dab right
excuse me
with the dabrite thermometer i have
yeah no it's perfect i really i rarely
have reclaim
but
if i do it's like a little smidge around
the water line i guess
and now i don't do anything with reclaim
but i have a lot of homies
that used to when we first started
dabbing they would get all that
reclaimed out dry it deck take a glob of
it
not for me all right
it's just not for me i
i don't know i don't think it's worth
the time to scrape up and dry out do
that rather just
i'm a snob very sorry but there's no
other way to put it i'm [__] stop
sorry
to answer your question
it
no planet earth gets my reclaim wherever
that water goes
all right wherever that water goes this
is where that reclaim goes but yes
sorry i would have never known that you
could do anything with reclam i thought
that's like resin smoke it again but
it's not not the best
how the [__] do you even get to it it's
in the bottom of your desk wash it out
you pour it out
oh
okay globs i i mean when he should smoke
shatter a lot and i would take slabs it
would spill over
and i would have grams of reclaim but
i've never done anything with it i used
to give it to my friends my friend
stevie too because he would try it out
make [__] edibles out of it so i
would give it to him so i stopped
wasting it i felt bad
but also
ah i'm not gonna sit here anymore yo i
gotta find somebody one day that wants
all this reclaim
with weed i put it in a [__] jar and
give it to somebody eventually like but
no
is it the last question
i think it might be let's see here
yes that is our first edition
of [__] fan videos fan video
questions there's a bug in here he's
literally doing exactly what he's
supposed to he's bugging the [__] out of
me i don't want to kill him i don't kill
him but i will stun you
[__] you guys that was just a fan quest
marty
[__] here we go guys that was 50 minutes
of fan questions
thank you for our first edition of video
fan questions if you ever want one of
your videos on the show we will ask on
the underscore dope wait
it's not the it's just opens usual we
have so many accounts
dope underscore as underscore usual
underscore podcast dope's usual podcast
on instagram check it out guys that's us
that's marty and i
send us your [__] questions all right
that's it we're going to always ask on
there on that or our twitter is the same
exact name check us out
click the link in the bio of instagram
to go to all of our platforms that's
everything it's so hard to tell you
twitter is this and there's an
underscore on this one the tick tock has
a period like i'm not gonna do that it's
[__] stupid you're not gonna remember
some of you just lost your keys right
now or curling where the [__] are my
keys
you're going to remember all those
underscores no
i don't
so
i'll take it off you
guys this story
story time coming up marty and i cannot
remember if we told it
and if i haven't then it's an untold
story time i've never talked about it
i've never talked about it on story time
i've never talked about it anywhere
i think
i've never made a video where the clip
of this i think you went over this with
me like bts one time maybe huh
it's a lot of that it's hard to it's
hard because sometimes guys when we
first started season one me and marty
what were setting up
would talk for an hour and a half
and then press play and go
wait did we talk about that what was
that before we started remember for
season one me and him would say that
we talked about that on camera or is it
before we start because it used to take
us so long to set up because we didn't
know what we were doing at first what we
did but
this cable turned to this cable this
adapter oh it's the adapter marty does
72 tries and goes all trial by error
it's the [__] outlet or something
stupid at the end we find out so would
take marty forever because
we didn't realize oh we need these and
these that's why we do it easy now like
we know what chords and we know what
shorts and
anyway
i don't know if we talked about the
story guys i have no [__] idea we
felt like it would have been a clip if
we had this story is [__] incredible
and the people i'm with makes it funnier
i hope to god i have not told this
[__] story yet because it's gonna be
stupid if two fans go yeah i know this
whole story [__] like [__] must be
alive
but i'm gonna tell you guys this story
and i told marty or before we started
the past couple of
solo episodes when i'm doing the chat i
felt something's off something's a
little different maybe it's not as
entertaining to me and i'm like yo am i
[__] up what am i doing wrong i told
marty this and i figured it out why it's
nothing wrong
i figured it out like inside internally
what i didn't like about the video that
was a [__] cloud what i didn't like
about the video you ready
when i'm telling stories the past couple
episodes i'm doing this so i'm gonna
play marty i'm at a [__] place right
i'm looking past the camera i'm talking
to marty and i'm doing this like so dude
i'm telling you the guy was [__]
gigantic or whatever i was talking about
in story times i've never done this
talking going
yo i'm telling you man so i think i'm
breaking the immersive feeling by going
yo mark and the next thing happened wait
morgan just wait it's it's not me
telling a story i'm telling a story to
marty and you guys are bts
when i'm talking to the camera i'm
telling you at home
and i think that's what happened when i
told the mushroom story i was so lost
that i was just staring at the camera
and during the chat i'm like
that's what my [__] problem is how do
i not because i don't have a formula i
just talk i just go on story time and
press play and talk
i didn't realize that breaking this is
what [__] breaks this
so in this story i'm gonna [__] stare
at this camera and i want you guys to be
fully immersed because this one's i've i
[__] hope you never heard it
there's no way you heard it but let me
give you a little setup
i'm not going to tell you which town or
which company because i don't want to
embarrass them
but it's a weed company
it was kind of near you marty their
headquarters kind of near you so not in
la but not in
irvine it's between irvine and l.a like
orange county i guess you would call it
so it's a legal company so they had a
warehouse what not
i was invited
are you ready
i'm ready
i was invited by this piece of [__] i
used to work with
[__] him he used to work with him
his wife or girlfriend who cares that's
why his girlfriend uh works with his
weak company and then
og knows his weak company too so i
invited og and his wife mindy
og
his wife mindy already hilarious ready
hilarious
combination
rosie and i
we're all friends
old [__] i used to work with is there
and his girlfriend's not really with us
because she works with them so she's
kind of doing the party
so they invite us to a party let's just
say this
they invite me to a party
i assume it's a party it's more of a
dinner
oh she's still gonna wear [__] jeans
and a crop uh a crew neck and a
backwards hat and glasses in the night
no matter where the [__] we're going
like he's not dressing up
everyone people wearing suits and ties
dresses
i was in vancouver it's a it's a
nighttime dinner party night dinner
high class dinner party these people
have a warehouse and they have a space
that's like really elegant bar dinner
spot really cool
so
let me start you off that's what i'm
thinking
like we're gonna go to this dinner it's
gonna be cool i don't wanna go i'm gonna
go anyway just because it'd be nice
i i'm one of those people that yo the
plans got cancelled [__] yeah even if i
was gonna go make a million dollars like
oh i don't have to do [__] sir
any chance that i can go
good cause i'm so [__] tired
and i don't have to make talk with
random [__]
thank god
that's me all right is hit marty in the
soul like me too man something better
nothing better like yeah i can't plants
cancel but i didn't so i'm like i'm
gonna go
so i get there
i get there
in a
scenario of a batman fight
it's a [__] parking lot with wood
pallets
a dumpster a light and a door i'm like
yo what super villains gonna come out
like clapping we've got you
am i being set the [__] up that's the
first thing i thought like yo i am in a
dark
parking lot of a warehouse
i have not met these people i'm going
based off your guys's invite don't like
it
that's what our guests think pulling up
here i know i know dude
i know man i was talking about it
yesterday we were talking about the
certain guests yesterday i'm like oh
y'all think we're robbing him like nah
man we had tony hawk in here like yeah
but you know what our [__] warehouse
i was like it looks like you're gonna
come out with less organs
it doesn't look friendly here
the inside's balling yeah we don't want
it that's why you would never know where
we're at guys
because you're like yeah they would not
be there right that's awesome
here we go
i'm like this
i'm like oh gee you got your gun on you
please i hope you do
like all right we're in a parking lot we
text the person i know piece of [__]
we're calling piece of [__] my old
partner
his girlfriend works here i know we're
not gonna get molested or anything we're
[__] robbed or stolen
but
i'm like yo what's up with this dank
alley not dankas and flash's fire dank
isn't like oh this place is dark and
damp i don't want to be here it might as
well had a blue filter on the bottom of
my eyes like yo
[__] this alley where batman's parents
were killed
that's how i felt door opens
to a very nice warehouse weed up i'm
like oh bomb cool
i walk up to the guy
at the front desk podium like he's gonna
give a speech
like it's a [__] restaurant like yo
they're really going all out here huh
they really want you to make you feel
like you're in hollywood okay that's
cool
and they go i need your phones to go
what
oh yeah there's no phones allowed inside
to go
you want me to give you my
phone maybe i am going to die
maybe i am going to die here
why the [__]
and og look to me like
i get my [__] phone oh
no man
and i'm sitting there
like sign your name and here's your
ticket for your phone and we give you
the ticket you put in the cubby
and you get your key and you get your
phone at the end i'm like
so it's locked
all right cool [__] it
i'm not gonna be that long [__] i
don't give a [__] we all reluctantly go
uh
here i'll fight you you know i'll bite
through your chest
i have a story about my dad you might
wonder before we go up there
anyway we go up this [__] staircase
it's dark
it's not well lit it should be they're
growing [__] weed with weed lights
turn one of them on please
that's how i felt like you'll just just
turn a light on
so i'm walking up these stairs like this
you know i've seen resident evil 2 i
know when the hands pop out and grab you
i am not down like you are i'm going up
this [__] staircase
we get up remember rosie
me og his wife dumb [__] piece of [__]
we are going up the stairs
we get to the top
the door opens
what a nice ass bar
slash dinner spot
like 1920s carved [__] crown molding
everywhere
a private set top and yaki area
baller stupid baller
i don't give a [__] i was like okay
we're not gonna be murdered i hope
we sit at our little spot and i'm like
all right cool
some white dudes in suits
i see a couple black chicks with afros
i don't know how to i feel like i think
we're okay here all right i think we're
okay if it was all
why'd you just look back harrison suits
i would feel like i need to leave
because they're all looking at me like
look at this guy with his fans on like
you invited me
that's how i felt like okay it's diverse
in here i don't feel like a get out
situation is going to happen
i think we're okay
because i was i'm
obviously like
like three gay chicks uh
yes i'm pretty diver we're cool we're
all brown
we're safe here and i looked around
automatically like how can i jump out if
we need to jump out i'm only on the
second floor i'm like looking like okay
one win on the back i do this everywhere
i go i hate it all right get out of here
all right cool
hi i do it at restaurants it's the worst
and uh
like yo it's gonna hurt
but there's a window right there if we
need to get out of here
and i know our car is like there and
over somewhere because the stairs went
guys the stairs were kind of dark i
remember i went up
took a left went up the next staircase a
left
past this little part of the wall
there's the door
right there's the door
to the [__] speakeasy open the door
and we let in
remember that that's a very vital piece
i don't just say [__] in stories that's
a very vital [__] piece
i left i took a left took a left left
there's a door two staircases left and a
door
remember that
i get in there let's go like all right
man that's that first city in here we're
good
[__]
we're sitting there um the owner of this
place comes up and i go ugh
i get like a like a
oh devil's advocate vibe from him i got
like a
way my hand off after this i don't want
your [__] energy on me i felt weird
he felt creepy
this is the suit the politician hi hello
oh you're drinking [__] liquor
straight
oh no just drinking a cup
with circle circle uh ice circle cubes
like circle ice you know those dope ones
with a leaf and full of liquor just
drinking like yo you have killed people
nobody drinks like that unless you've
like trying to suppress some [__]
demons
you're crazy
i meet him and he's like yeah i have
seen your videos i'm like okay cool
thanks
[__] american psycho here that's how
i felt met his wife
she's odd
they're nice
they're odd they're nice
sorry guys let me speed it up now that
we're there boom you get this whole
background you see where i'm at i'm with
og me and him feel like this like i'll
[__] kill somebody you know that i'm
like i will kill them with you
i am i feel odd already giving my phone
up and then going up these weird-ass
staircases already feel weird the drink
menu was only five drinks and they were
all no mixes they were all liquor only
with fruit in it or a bitter i guess
it's called in a sugar cube or whatever
it's called i've never had it
but i was sitting there i went with
like my breath you could have lit on
fire i'm like oh my [__] god
i'm like these folks are trying to get
fools faded in here there was about 30
people guys
25 girls and like five dudes
okay
it's like 25 chicks to five dudes
oh no
this will trying to bang like a bunch of
[__] at once that's how it felt like
yo come in with myself nice to meet you
you know that's how i felt like look at
my establishment my weed operation
that's how i felt legal so it's all
really nice
that's how i felt like uh
i get the vibe from him like you know
who my father is that's the vibe i got
like ugh you do own this place huh might
be a nice dude got a creepy vibe anyway
uh
standing around let me speed this up
standing around doing dinner party
things drinking a drink i drink one
drink i'm like i'm not drinking more
than that [__] this [__] that's nasty
you put a sugar cube in it that was the
chaser the mixer was a sugar cube
i'm not a [__]
racist in the 80 in 1900s like i don't i
need more than just liquor and sugar
cubes for my horse
you [__]
that's all i felt like yo you drink like
eight of them since been standing here
man you're an alcoholic
and you're still proper and sober this
man is a [__] alien
i don't know i'm just processing all
these things in my head going in here 30
minutes i could probably leave soon i've
been here for him i could probably leave
soon i know just looking at me late
yeah let's get the [__] i'm looking
at him but i'm with piece of [__] [__]
and his girlfriend works there so i'm
not gonna be like all right
sorry you're here alone i'm out i didn't
want to do that right
so
here we go sorry guys speed it up ready
go guy does this ding ding ding on the
glass [__] i go oh
i don't like this i don't want to be
here he dinged on the side of his glass
like
like we're adults or something come on
man we're in a weed operation you don't
gotta do that
anyway he starts giving this speech guys
i'm not listening i don't give a [__] he
gave me the creeps and the thing that
caught my attention in this conversation
and i saw og do this because he's like
two people the way he goes
i didn't need to look at rosie i knew
rosie was already looking at me i just
did this one
and i saw oh gee i'm like okay you heard
that all right let's make it sure
[__] fool's talking giving a speech
there are no prejudices here
blah blah blah he's like looking towards
like the lesbian chicks like
okay you're really trying to go for that
politician [__] i love all people that's
how he was
there are no prejudices here and he
looks at the gay chicks like bro
you should have looked like to the right
of him a little
like i love mexicans as he holds og's
arm that's how he did that one like were
no prejudices
see i invited him that's basically what
he said
there are no prejudices here
you know do what you want drink what you
want
put in your body
whatever you want
or put in someone else's body whatever
you feel
whatever you desire put in your body or
in someone else's body and i was like
shut the [__] up did this man just say
i'm trying to get the orgy started but
i'm a little shy so let me beat around
the bush
he said whatever you want to put in your
body and i went
i looked lg
all right just making sure that you
heard what i heard
i look around and nobody's like doing
the eye i'm like
kind of party i come to man
a lot of chicks a couple dudes let's see
what's happening here
so
tonight's going on and the guy goes all
right we're going to sit down for dinner
do me a favor
say hello to the person next to you
switch seats go sit with a person that
you don't know don't sit next to a
person you know if you came with them
don't sit with the table
and i looked at you i'm not [__]
doing that you want to know how it ended
up
mindy og me rosie at one table
everyone else mixed up we looked across
a piece of [__] [__] is doing this
he sat at a different table didn't get
the
didn't see me do that i don't know
i'm not moving you think i'm gonna go
sit with a stranger you're [__]
stupid
i'm very
to myself in public i'm not gonna unless
you say something be super friendly and
nice and hi how are you doing
i'm not gonna go opt to go do the [__]
especially after you said put in your
body [__] i'm like yo i didn't want to
eat this food i'm about to wake up in
the morning i don't the [__] in this
[__] i'm cool
anyway he's looking at me like what the
[__] he's like us piece of shit's like
us he doesn't want to be over there
either he didn't see the memo of me
going no i'm not going anywhere
and we stayed for like 30 minutes
everybody stood up after having an
appetizer to get more drinks and we went
and tried to leave
right
our piece of [__] his girlfriend's like
you guys are leaving already
i get it
it's weird i'm like oh so you understand
that it's weird here it wasn't over the
top it was an underlying sense of
you might get [__] penetrated
in your sleep
that's how i felt like nah i don't like
this place
guys one of the stairs left
went up the next stairs took a left
space of a wall door guy opened the door
correct
everybody paying attention remember i
said that i really remember that
i go out this [__] door
i go to the right because now i'm going
opposite
there's no staircase anymore there's a
[__] wall over the staircase
are you hearing what i'm saying
i went
i looked back at og because nobody's
letting us out we just [__] like i'm
out it's the guy i didn't know over the
door we just opened the door
these [__] slid a [__] door
over that staircase and there was
another staircase on the opposite side
that took me in all these [__]
directions and when i got back off i was
on the opposite side of the [__] grow
room
no lights
dim as [__]
you're trying to get girls shit-faced
change the [__] direction on how to
leave so they don't know where they're
at and they don't have their phone they
don't know how to go get their phone how
are they going to get out of here if
they didn't drive
what the [__] what is this place this is
like the plot of saw i felt odd man
when i saw that there was a door and i
my map i went left left left so it's a
right right right to get the [__] out of
here
yeah i knew what i was doing i'm
cautious when i went
and i touched it and it went
like it was a sliding door like
are you fools trying to [__] do
something to me
not just me like
what kind of party did i come to
why did you feel the need to change the
exit
why
that's the part that got me pissed off
change the [__] exit is that why your
drinks are so strong
you took my [__] phone i just felt
weird i felt weird played as [__] we all
looked at you like what the [__] i just
opened the door
i mean i mean i didn't open the door
i slid the other [__] door and there
was a staircase the staircase was it was
another staircase
but it wasn't it wasn't like they hid
and there was no way out there was like
a door halfway open there's another
staircase on the left
but why why hide the first one why'd you
why do you have two staircases and one
you hide
you're [__] weirdos
so i hope i never told that story
and just remember guys
imagine what ogee was doing they're
saying that's what i was reading through
this whole thing
hey folks
see this [__] you say put in you
whatever you want to put in you
basically imagine to put his body in my
body yeah imagine thinking what oh
imagine his reaction to all of this
i was starving anyway y'all were hungry
as [__] i was like i ain't trying to eat
this [__]
i'm kind of good so you guys dipped out
before an hour and ten minutes off hour
and ten minutes i was like i'm [__]
out of here not too long later
og saw
the wife somewhere at a convention
and she tried to invite him twice to the
party stopped by his [__] twice to give
him a ticket to the new parties that
they're doing
and he's all when she gave it to me she
looked at me like she wanted me to take
my pants off it's like i know that look
it's like oh get away from me like oh
gee
that's what was going down huh i think
they were trying to see who the [__] was
down
and they changed the staircase in case
you weren't down they go just just chill
just wait
or you're too drunk to leave i don't
know what the [__] situation was i
didn't like the situation that's all i
got to say
leading people down a dark maze that
leads nowhere is not cool
mad upscale and elegant inside
that's [__] weird
i don't know if i've ever told that
story i think i have
i feel like i have
but if i have it there you go oh gee was
with me so was he as mad as you were he
was all bad he was so bad piece of [__]
[__] was way more mad because he had to
sit by himself for 25 minutes because he
didn't see the memo of like
why didn't you just get up because we
all had already sat down like i started
talking again it's like a room double
this size marty
that's it
that's it dude like little dainty chairs
and antique furniture
in a huge space no it's a little [__]
like bar slash
and then where the offices is the top
and yankee where the chef's cooking and
they bring the food out on like five
course dinners and like all fancy with
like uh like
sugar that's been melted to look like
shards and your ice cream those kind of
places
and i was like yo this is baller where's
the exit
that's all i felt like this is baller i
don't like it
um
anyway
imagine og
it was amazing the second we got life
and went back out went
why are we in a different door oh this
is [__] weird if i was a drunk girl
two hours later
this might be hard to leave with no
phone um we had to go back and the guy
was like oh you're leaving oh yeah i
need my phone man give me my [__] i'm
adding like i'm [__] gone he looks
like you're out of here
yeah you [__] or something you guys
ain't [__]
there's no prejudice here you know that
right i mean look we invited him that's
basically what the whole party was
never again
never again this is why we don't go
places this is why i go nowhere i
remember thinking i will [__] kill
you if i have to
if there's no door on the other side of
this
there's no stairs
well i've never had anybody change the
staircase accident on me before that's
real creepy i just started freaking the
[__] out i didn't freak out just because
when i turned this way it was cracked
open like another sliding door but when
i walked up i didn't pay attention and
saw the slide noise i was a wall
remember i took a left and then the guy
opened the door i'm like oh i didn't go
it's a wall or door i didn't see that
but it was so dark
so you don't see that it's a [__]
door if the lights are on you're like oh
it's a sliding door
you see the wheels at the bottom but it
was so dark it's like a nightclub
walking into it
um
that's the story
could've ended a lot worse
this whole time
damn i rolled the fat one for the story
and i forgot
[__] it's okay so that's the story i
really hope i didn't say it
before but guys that was a story time
for the episode
i have something new coming up for you
all right
if you follow me on twitter if you don't
it's dopaziola i think
with underscores in between each word i
believe yes and on the end and on the
end marty knows he does all my [__]
graphics and pops it in every week
so go follow my twitter
for a couple years i've been doing some
things called [__] my friends say
and i decided
[__] the twitter spaces
i'm gonna do that here i'm not actually
[__] when i love twitter [__] putting
it on twitter i'm gonna start doing [__]
my friends say on the podcast
i went through my notes recently
remember i get deleted a lot so i don't
keep the same ip i don't keep the same
apple id so i lose a lot of my notes so
if i've done 17 or if i've done 20 000
notes
i've lost like [__] six of them 6 000
of them
i've lost a good percentage of my notes
man not really thousands but let's just
say that was kind of dumb i could just
say that i have a thousand
i'm so burnt
i was like damn you take i'm [__]
slipping on my nose i thought i thought
i don't know i have a lot of stupid
amount anything i think of my bro right
away
um
so i started going through every note in
my phone when i was in merced because i
got to do something on this downtime or
just chilling i'll just be productive
somehow
and i went through every note and marked
it as joke
this
[__] my friends say movie idea joke idea
stand up nice character movie reference
movie characters you should do the skit
content i just did it as that so i went
through and i pulled some things from a
segment i am introducing today and it's
gonna be called [__] my friends say
are you [__] ready for the [__] that
my friends say to me yes all right i
know one on the top of my head i'll just
uh you know no no no let's do this right
let's do this right let me light this
[__] joint this joint is a baby
joint for everyone on the road it's like
a point one
um smallest joint ever on the show
really lightable barely lightable i like
that
i barely lied it's a [__] monster
today
this is like the shark from uh
that movie what was it is it finding
nemo bruce
the shark with the accent i think it's
finding nemo
looks like that
or it could be fish tails or whatever
that's stupid it's called here we go
guys i have these on my phone i bring
these up in my notes are you [__]
ready
here we go
uh this is the very first installment of
[__] my friends say
okay
this one is from my friend charlie
you know charlie charlie is a my friend
he used to be he's helped me with
videography
did you watch the flower or my first
weed commercial vlog the guy that i said
the director that's charlie
charlie's a [__] actor you probably
know charlie from [__] girls shows
charlie's a lot of girls shows on
netflix
he's the love interest
charlie's like a good looking white kid
so he
he's the man he's funny
so
i want to give you a background of this
character so when i tell you that he's
an actor a trained actor in movies and
all this [__]
so the fact that this is a movie
reference makes it better i have to tell
you what this person is like first
charlie's really good he's an actor he
does lines the script he's he's saying
that he has a great memory
are you ready i wrote this down
charlie we were just chilling in santa
rosa one time at a [__] event and he
and we're at the house he goes help me
i'm falling i can't get up we all know
that from like the old people help line
from the 90s help i've fallen and i
can't get up charlie's also like seven
years younger than me so the
generational gap here
all right he's a
little generational gap slightly
charlie says help i fall and i can't get
up and he goes
pretty
pretty sure that's rambo
or is that rambo two i know it's one of
those
and i look at charlie and go
that's a geriatric commercial that's a
life alert yeah
and i wrote it down charlie
i think i think you're right
he had to [__] guess second guess me
on help i've fallen i can't get up
that's rambo oh no is that rambo two
first off it's ramble first blood
oh [__] kill you charlie
i love that fool sorry i have to give
you the background that this trained
actor got this [__] wrong so hold on
he's they said that in rambo no
like he got shot wait wait no rambo two
like you knew from the first time
just having trouble distinguishing which
one
which
rambo first blood
okay sorry that's just that's just i i
write these exactly how they happen
dialogue i stop i move i write it
exactly how it happened because i'm
going to put these into
shows one day as certain characters
like this character is a [__] oh
charlie said some [__] one time he
should be saying [__] like this that's
why i write these out it's for character
references so charlie thank you for
giving me a stoner stoner guy because
what the [__]
rambo i i
think you're right i think you're right
it's about the complete opposite of a
life alert commercial thank you bro
thank you it's an old lady going help i
thought you guys know the commercial
sorry let's move on sorry here we go
let's move on
friend talk
all right [__] my friends say this is my
friend aaron aaron is out of jail by the
way for everyone out there remember like
eight months ago i'm like oh my friend
went to jail he was supposed to call
it's right after the episode he called
he was then they booked him late he just
got to jail so shout out to aaron he's
out
um
one time we're at my house we're just
really drunk backstory we're just really
drunk
and aaron's talking and he's just
focused in this conversation so i have a
big black sharpie and i do what things
that [__] do
and or
hilarious humans
i just
periodically go over to aaron like yo
what's up y'all he's up on your neck oh
you're good to go periodically grab his
shoulder when i do it right on his neck
at the same time she doesn't feel it
20 minutes in i've marked aaron 40 times
all on his on his actual cheek it's
gotten to the point where he's watching
me do this i'm just right on his face
and he goes did you really do him like i
did
i'm sorry
anyway
eric comes up to me here it is this is
[__] my friends say it's like 40 minutes
after i've done it i have video i'm
sending the video where he's just marked
to death he's so shit-faced it doesn't
matter
and this is it ready i love this segment
right here he looks and he goes yo i
trust you
it comes up to me mid party everyone
talking at my house just about like 15
people in my house we're all just
getting [__] up
and he's in my ear he goes yo i trust
you
but is there a dick on my neck
i did
or did this with his phone
why'd he come up to me that's how drunk
he was i had to take advantage of that
i mean he was standing up when i drew on
him
he was made conversation drinking going
stop oh i'm like oh i swear to god i
didn't do anything
did you write on me like if you think i
didn't ride on you then you deserve to
be ready
i'm sorry aaron
um
i have the video marty please don't
during the edit please please let me
give it to you i do pov like this
me walking around the house and i smash
him and he's taking a shot as i oh i
can't wait for the video okay sorry
sorry sorry moving on
moving on
this one's great i have a friend named
baby his real birth name is baby he's a
boy
he hated it hey baby hey little baby oh
don't act like a baby
until he's about eighth grade and go
as soon as you started liking girls how
cool was like oh it's the best [__]
name ever you know how the ice breaker
for any girl how what's your name my
name is baby no it's not no that's my
name
like oh she's so honestly like no my
name is baby
crushes it
so this is a long time ago dude this is
from like four phones ago
i'm sorry to put him on blast he doesn't
do drugs like that anymore but
this is the area i wrote down
4 30 in the morning
my friend is vaping
e-cigarette
doing lines
doing rails of coke taking fat dabs and
drinking liquor
a combination of wonders and he looks at
me and goes
why the [__] is my mouth so dry and i
put and he was dead serious when he
looked at me
this man went
why is my mouth so dry while he's
hitting rails
vaping dabbing and drinking shots
just the things that my friends say to
me on a daily basis makes me laugh
it makes me happy inside does coke dry
your mouth out too
whether it does or not
you're on drugs and you're drunk and
you're vaping and dabbing drink some
water
mouth so dry why
i remember looking i'm like are you
[__] kidding me baby
it's 4 30 in the morning man you're
still doing rails
come on little baby
you know in my phone now his name and my
phone is adult baby
because i don't want somebody going oh i
need to text rosie he has my phone on an
emergency or something text baby by
accident sorry i hope not but
you know what i mean i had to change
that [__]
um so he said that to me i have so many
of these and there's scenarios so the
reason i'm saying this to you because
you got to imagine these in skit form
yeah you got to imagine these photos
like how og calls people weasel tests
and shows
are you ready are you guys ready oh it
gets
these
hold on we're not even halfway done
you ready
next one this is from monica monica is
rosie's best friend forever
monica's awesome monica's also dumb as
hell sometimes she does the funniest
[__]
she's telling me
we're just talking smoking weed and
she's like yo i went to the liquor
stores like the [__] guy shows that
her husband's like he's like what guy
he's like you know the guy that always
says that to me oh yeah he goes he calls
me cosplay girl and go
why
she
she looks at me goes because once
[__] one time i walked in with a
sword on my back
and ever since then i go monica you've
walked in with a [__] sword i would
call you cosbo or [__] anything
forever you think they're not gonna
forget you that's your store i walk in
with a sword once and i wrote it because
the way she said it made me laugh like
[__] real sword no a cosplay
sword of course they're gonna call you
cosplay girl
you're the only girl in merced walking
in with a sword to the liquor store when
people say cosplay that just means
somebody in a costume right i guess or
[__] no
but that
is the girl in my show and she says [__]
like that
so guys [__] my friends say are gonna be
things our friends say for the rest of
your life and your favorite shows coming
up one day
that's how i'm planning this out that
just made me laugh just just
it's ridiculous i'm sorry
this was a quick one i just thought it
was really funny see these are tweets
these are tweets but i don't think
twitter needs it i think we need to talk
about this on the [__] podcast all
right here we go john hash house
this is him talking i fired my personal
trainer me why
him
because i just want to be fat again
and that's it
it's the end of the conversation the
most honest thing of all time because i
just want to be fat again that's what he
told me
and he was serious he hasn't gone back
to that trainer
um and i always write the person's name
just says john
i always do this guys i'm sorry there's
there's there's more some of these are
just very basic but some of them are
[__]
funny
uh damn i haven't seen this [__]
forever
this one you can actually see on camera
in the weed release remember when i
released my own weed and i got on the
bus with all the fans we had a smoke out
my friend paulo this is from paulo this
is on camera but you can
you have to really listen to the [__]
you can if you watch that video you can
see it happen you gotta really listen
this [__] on camera without
knowing prairie dogs has a little head
in the frame and goes
someone's smoking sativa in here [__]
freaking out because he hates the team
but the way he said it was like a [__]
i can't find her pills
[__] freaking out
so yeah you could tell the difference
between sativa and indica marty big time
so could paulo
my friend apollo started the high
society you guys remember instagram high
society
one of the biggest pages on instagram
remember that [__] we instagram and high
society that's how i got my start they
started posting me on their page
remember this is the guy
uh i thought it was funny um
yeah so here we go let's get on to the
worst ones or the the
funnier ones to me
this is just my friend named justin all
right it's not justin boyd it's another
friend named justin
me
eating a pop-tart about to open a
pop-tart it was a nature wells one i
don't eat pop-tarts anymore i can
i'm trying to be more healthy
i'm opening i go hey justin do you want
a pop-tart and he goes
nah well
maybe like half of one i just did some
lines
just like no i'm kind of tired no just
let me get a half a pop tart i just did
some lines and i go you did you did just
do some lines so here's a half a pop
tart see i love drugs my friends some of
my friends still do drugs i just i don't
do them i stare at them do i go that
looks fun
but i just remember how knowledgeable
like nah i just did some lines i'm good
on repo
yeah i'm full that's the [__] vibe i
got no i just ate
that's just one of them
this is funny oh i shouldn't that's what
he did to me
here's another one from justin sorry to
put you on blast on this one this one's
get away from me bug this one's really
funny
you ready
my friend tells me man at the birthday
party
they refused to serve me more drinks
he's like i got so drunk i'm like yo
what parties those
birthday party i'm like
oh you got drunk on the birthday party
like dude where were you
and he just put his head down i was like
chuck e cheese man
and i go oh your five-year-old
daughter's birthday party
just the way you set it up i'm like oh
you got a party it's cool you got cut
off it happened chuck e cheese
for your daughter's birthday you got cut
off
that's so [__] embarrassing
just pushing the kids out of the way the
basketball game oh you get cut off at
chuck e cheese it's the most insane [__]
i've ever heard
no i'm half a pop-tart i just did a line
same guy i love this man
yo that
that's funny that's like an
accomplishment to me though that's
something that you can carry with you
for your life
yeah that's [__] incredible bro
that's [__] amazing
all right you know what that was the
last one i'm gonna end it there too
anyway i don't want to give them all
away there's
there's a lot of offensive ones maybe
next solo will swing a few there's a lot
there's a lot on here dude this episode
just got away from us yeah
what do we have like two hours yeah
oh man
[__] my friends say
ah there's a segment oh marty we really
got sidetracked on this one yeah
[__] it this was rant city if it's ever
been
guys i'm high i guess because i i it
could be two in the afternoon
man [__] as far as that goes i'm
yeah delirious the [__]
all right
uh we this was a long episode that was
supposed to be very tightened
but the questions just kept going like
the questions kept us just
talking sorry
that's all right i always always like
crush my cans
you should make cans like this it you
can grip it cool
that's why i do it it's [__] cool
it's like bong it's like the grooves of
the ice catcher and the bong uh-huh
that's funny
miller light
if you ever want to do something brand
ambassador ran ambassadors right here
may just make me one with a
rip it
um
anything you want to add marty this is
one of the last solos for a minute yeah
we'll see we're just we're taking this
as it comes we're hustling this week
i feel good to be here i've been waiting
for this all day but i'm about to get
right back to it tomorrow and get this
thing edited and
handle all the [__] this weekend i've
just been trying to tie i've just had a
lot of loose ends it feels good to like
make the calls you don't want to make
make the appointments you don't want to
make get the [__] done that's just been
lingering and looming
i'm trying to get all that done now and
just this next week just come out fresh
new situations new chapters i can feel
that
shit's about to get way cooler
all right
i wish we could talk about everything
but we can't
that's all right guess what baby steps
we're gonna we're gonna look back it's
not gonna be too long when we look back
and think of these as the early days of
the show 100 percent we're gonna go damn
look at our [__] set oh my god
like i did with the doubles i was on a
[__] iphone to grow light
oh man we're gonna walk in and go hey
i don't need to ask if anything set up
right it's set up right right all right
we're going to get up and running and
then the vlog is going to start and
we're going to leave there we go
start over
exactly that's exactly what we're going
to i can't [__] wait for marty's days
a week or podcast
two of mine essentially in the middle of
the whole day or our podcast
the premiere filming it
so extra for marty
so if you have those back
more content
more cool [__]
all right
i think that's everything i think that's
pretty much everything man uh remember
jerry springer's final thought
i think that's
marty michael marty what's your final
thought
you're gonna turn to camera five and go
well well today what did we learn yeah
yeah you automatically have a blazer on
uh-huh what did we learn today never
trust american psycho when he's serving
you straight liquor and got you know a
diverse crowd of people that you don't
know how you [__] fit into you look
like gavin news literally he looked like
a governor and it made me feel like
you look like apollo it's bug this bog
oh
you hate her you just made me blow in
the ashtray bug
gotcha [__] he went right over it
[__] it's probably my beer
now we're good
um all right sorry here we go guys i'm
gonna try to tighten this up uh
so today
on the podcast so the dope's usual
podcast we had marty's final thought and
his final thought is make those calls
you don't want to make get [__] done and
new chapters in life
it's coming soon
no not bad yeah sounded better when you
said it ah i'm chewing my uh
okay around the derby
voice when i'm
talking about horses and racing
um today real quick for a guy i watched
the story of rolex
the other day i watched the story of
louis vuitton and the story of gucci
all three made by [__] homeless kids
pretty wild
rolex story the guy that made real like
that was a baller story
go watch that [__] on youtube it was
pretty balanced the dumb ass narration
the narration was terrible the story was
baller the gucci story super cool it was
crazy thinking of all these [__]
brands that have been around for a
hundred years plus
wow
rolex their story on how they got
popular it's amazing best marketing i
ever seen in my life they're waterproof
so all department stores he had a
[__] goldfish bowl with live goldfish
and a [__] watch hanging in it says
world's first waterproof watch
the girl that swam the english channel
he put one on her so when she was doing
it she's like look my watch is still
good it's a rolex bro he this
[__] is a marketing genius dude
his for his new underwater diver with
the submariner the mariner watch he had
the world's deepest divers wear it when
they did a [__] world dive came up
and it was still working yeah
there's more crushing [__] over here
that's the kind of [__] we need
like michael phelps
he [__] smoked our weed and won the
[__] olympics
he came back and he's fine
that's the story time joint yeah with a
story time joy between his teeth he's
six five
he's tall trust him
that's pretty much it
all right okay everyone should talk
about i watched on youtube today i also
watched a one-armed guy
i tell you this sorry real quick
i gotta find the name of the page it's
handicapped fights not because they're
disabled handicapped fights is two on
one
two girls versus one guy
two guys versus one girl
yesterday i clicked on i went this isn't
real it says one-armed fighter versus
man and his son
the guy came through with the lights and
they introduced him
he threw his arms up with a boxing glove
on and had one piece of an arm on the
side
with a glove and i'm not watching this
i'm turning this off right now he really
has one [__] arm and he's about to
fist fight two people
i'm not watching this [__] i can't
believe this is like a
celebrity death match in real life type
[__] this is getting crazy idiocracy is
very close guys [__] don't even
drink water no more it's getting close
have you seen the idiocracy no you need
to go watch that [__] to oh you're
tired you go watch idiots see you and
like an april love it um we gotta get
out of here this is rant [__] city
over here guys i'm very sorry i'm one of
you just talking all i did was do
paperwork today and to cash rods and pen
hits and dabs
i'm burnt
marty i feel like we've been here for
[__] days
this episode's so long man
okay we'll get out of here guys to
conclude this
super baller cool shirt thanks mom um to
goodfell is a good movie
rayleigh would have passed away that's
super sad
um
[Music]
guys try to
swindle us into an orgy
that's weird too smart for that shot too
smart
too crafty i also had og there and he
ain't gonna go for that [__]
he's gonna shoot you
could you imagine
oh we got these people in our warehouse
they ain't going oh he shot me
we checked for phones and not guns
weasel tested shut
shot my dick up
i don't know it's all legal guns by the
way you guys don't think oh geez out
here being a [__] menace to society
nerf yeah that's a nerf nerf gun
it's legal though for sure
this is a long time ago also it was
[__] incredible
anyway thank you guys so much for being
here man uh today's episode
[__] [__] today's episode is all
over the place we got a lot of
[__] coming up might be a porn
star might be a fighter
might be a comedian might be some of my
favorite people on earth all
hypotheticals all hypotheticals
we're just talking here
we're just talking [__] right oh die
every time i look up i read dmx we gotta
cover that [__]
my brain can't look at that and keep and
not scream
into the [__] i respect that yeah
it's not gonna happen also why isn't dmx
on [__] def jam fight for new york
why the [__] is in dmx character it
would have been this is [__] this is
jordan [__] bro
sorry i googled it while i was playing
def jam and my mom's the other day i
went and says unlock dmx character oh
shut the [__] up i played for four hours
trying to get extra [__] points
bought it it was a made-up character
there was a silhouette of a gun it
clicked i'm like oh my god dmx won't
it was move made-up rapper ah
why wasn't jay-z or naz in there by the
way
miles wasn't assigned to death jam until
doesn't matter neither was [__] snoop
dogg when he's the main character and
from l.a
i don't [__] know the main characters
it's like the tony hawk game they just
picked and really could get or whatever
i don't know
i don't know man i don't know but it was
cool it was cool great game [__]
awesome danny trejo six foot tall in
that [__] game for some reason why is
danny trejo in def jam i don't [__]
know
danny trejo is in it but dmx isn't
that japanese questions
game
bring that [__] game back right now
with new rappers and you have a [__]
cult classic on your hands
bring it back so people can be young
thug fighting people
stop you
do you get the concept like y'all be
kendrick lamar you'll be kanye west and
we're just gonna throw [__] uh emblem
i mean music notes at each other
for our specials or something i don't
know
too tight also sorry real quick last
thing you guys doing with celebrity
death matches
why can't we bring that back
celebrity deathmatch video game
oh
oh celebrity deathmatch video game
and i said you got to be like alec
baldwin and like his finishers like you
get in the way of his prop gun or
something that's some kind of [__]
celebrity death match would do yeah they
would crush earth right now if they
brought that show back let alone a game
[__] out of here sorry wasted you guys
time someone stayed with me talking
about [__] i couldn't even tell you
what i said
well i have no [__] clue
guys thank you so much for being here
this is the dope as usual podcast we're
here to talk about a bunch of stuff
nothing some other stuff and stuff we
don't remember until the edit
dmx mostly just dmx actually just dmx
and 90's references
do you want to join us though
yo sorry last thing before i get out of
here
i see a lot of other podcasts
that are crazy numbers and i go wait
that's what and then i really oh you
guys are famous
you're at four mil on this channel
that's what it is i'm like yo you guys
get crazy gas on there but i watched the
up i'm not doubting anything i'm like
nothing special what oh you have 15
[__] million followers
gotcha
now i understand how you got these
people i'm always like
you know i think people want to be it's
fun here do you want to get hot you're
going to have to get high it's fun here
though
and oh because they think oh it's maybe
it's the warehouse
maybe it's the they look at my instagram
and go
he's got 2 000 followers and he made it
today
you want me to trust this guy
he has an instagram a day old
you know what i mean
it's hard man it's hard
but thank you guys for supporting so
much that the fact that we got some of
our favorite people on earth in this
room
and in this building alone pretty
[__] cool and
it's just a star this is mid season too
so thank you guys so much for being here
um
yeah we're literally in mid-june i mean
mid [__] season season two we're
barely getting started so thank you guys
so much for being here appreciate it i
think
that we gotta end this [__] we gotta go
we gotta go marty's marty's gotta drive
home still then edit and wake up and
[__] go film google [__]
pretty cool though
pretty cool
all right guys thank you so much for
marty from being a shitty buffalo for me
and being a shitty merced always
remember you don't have to stay there
forever you can always do some cool [__]
and go back go damn you [__]
still doing the same [__] that's crazy
be that guy don't be the guy going dance
[__] come back all bluesy no i
just grew up [__]
you could be that guy too man just
[__] try your hardest and that was
hypothetical i just made that up but you
guys feel me what the [__] i'm saying
you don't have to stay forever and if
you do it's totally cool but remember if
marty can make it out of there and do
what he's doing and i can make it out of
merced and do what i'm doing
i guarantee you guys got some [__] if
you have a [__] head on your
shoulders and some drive
you're gonna be pretty good all right so
as our
conclusion always do better don't be a
[__] work hard don't be a [__] and
work hard again and you've got this [__]
all right that's that's a [__] shirt
that's a shirt right there and it only
works when you sweat and does one of
those things where it's like a
sweatshirt it reveals the reveals the
words exactly thank you guys so much for
being here guys
look at that
all right for marty and i have the dope
as usual podcast this has been another
episode have a dope as day yo what the
[__] man
marty
shortest notes ever i'm like yo it's
gonna be it's gonna be the quick ass
episode let's be quick
damn dude
that was ours
[Music]